all right hello everyone welcome to yet
another version 14 design review
we are getting ready for something that
doesn't wait which is the eclipse of the
Sun in April right of 2024 yes
um
there's actually going to be another one
this month in the 14th
okay where's the visible from
um well the the maximum eclipse is going
to be somewhere in Mexico here in the US
we will see a partial eclipse in Mexico
it will be annular
okay it's not total this time that's
right it's not that's not such a big
deal exactly
okay
all right so where do we start here
I think we go again to the page of solar
eclipse it's solo Eclipse new
and have you updated the recommendation
oh I didn't not in the last uh within
the last hour
this is updated within the last hour
uh perhaps we keep adding things to the
page so I think it would be safer to
update okay
okay
just coming here
and which version of prototype is this
one
I don't know let's take a look
perfect
seems modern since it's the same date as
today yep
okay
is it like that yep
okay all right what to look at
it so okay so we can have a look at
various properties but something that we
are wondering right now if you go to the
first example I have a I have a
reasonable basic question okay things
like this that picture presumably if I
go to the notebook version of
documentation I will find that as vector
graphics true
if you go to one sorry the notebook
version the the the in product version
of documentation I will find that image
as vector graphics is that a true
statement you should yes so assuming
that it's not so big that we're forced
to rasterize it but that that graphic
should be relatively small so here's my
question in general with all this
illustration that's going into
uh documentation
you know I can imagine wanting to use
that for you know various kinds of
educational materials and so on and the
question is how can you lift it out of
there and have it be I mean I'm just
wondering whether we should have a click
to copy for these things
do you see what I'm saying yep
I mean Roger that would be a general
thing for yeah no it is I mean so I
um
in the notebook it's definitely it
depends on how what the author did so
most of the time is going to be vector
graphics
um but even if it's not a click to copy
would be yes and people are actually
doing that so we started to see it show
up in various kinds of articles
yeah these illustrations that we we are
now creating so for instance if you go
to complex plot like it tells you how
you spot a zero and uh and a pole and
like essential Singularity and I've seen
that now show up like in many many uh
articles and textbooks okay straight
copied straight out would be nice if
they referenced us do they
um maybe not for the illustration but
for yeah yeah
um
okay
and I just saw a book this morning on
statistics and it copies straight out
sort of the the explanations we did for
box whisker okay that's nice the
particularly right if
um
no we should tag those things that's
good and contact the authors and say
thanks
or growl at them as they did something
unreasonable well maybe we should have
some kind of
maybe we should say how people cite
things you know yeah we probably should
for these pictures yeah I mean if this
thing had a mouse had a had a tool tip
would make it easier
yeah
and if it had a click to copy
that had something that had you know
I found that by the way so already when
we started as many years ago
that when I give presentations
you know for you know introducing a new
concept using that illustration is like
super good way to introduce the concept
so yeah so let's look maybe we need to
click to copy and the thing which is
copied in the click to copy contains
some little signature
yes
okay I think that's something like that
we should figure out all right okay so
that's a separate
um
project and that should go to the folks
who are doing project management for
documentation right
in terms of where this actually happens
who is who is
doing projects Christian I am yes listen
pass to the docs team
okay
all right
so something else that Jeff and I have
have been investing in this regard is is
illustrations that move because in Astro
time it's so important that when you see
how things move you typically get a
better idea of what's going on well it
was getting very fancy I've never heard
of an antomber but it's sort of easy to
figure out what it must mean exactly
yeah we want to put the three names in
this it's going to be call-outs and
stuff right so tell us what to do
exactly yeah and that obviously should
be a spelling word
um yeah so monitoring the three concepts
is the key thing in all this problem
okay so this is this in the end is a
problem of the geometry of the
intersection of an ellipsoid and a cone
and The Cone is moving in the ellipsoid
is rotating and tilted so all these
angles intervene but that's all for that
so we're on the ellipsoid exactly
um we also have geo-elevation on the lip
side yeah so one can aim uh specify the
the position of the Observer and the
Observer has the three degrees of
freedom latitude longitude elevation
okay
but so when you yeah okay all right so
let's take a look here so what should we
look at here so let's go down a bit to
the basic examples and we have a map
and something we are wondering is
whether this type of map we have
improved it a bit from from I mean Jeff
has been working with team and on this
and um we are wondering whether this
deserves its own function rather than a
property in in solar eclipse
very specific thing I mean
with a lot of detail I mean in in um
well the idea of a function would be
that user could then specify Styles and
have control of that whereas if it's a
property they just get what we we decide
yeah and for example specify a region I
mean what happens is you just want to
see what's going on near Dallas so I
mean what will we call it solar eclipse
map
it could be I mean the the other
Geographics or I mean it reminds me
of
sort of the overlay of of um uh
geovisible region and things like this
right because the users can extract All
The Primitives from solar eclipse one by
one and provide access to all these
elements but then of course it's it's
very many and reconstructing
well so I mean so what you're suggesting
is that the correct way to do this would
be something like Geographics just like
we can say
uh you know if I say something like
Geographics
of Geo visible region of ISS for example
I should get
why did we just crash here
just crashed
let's try it again
I could try this in the release build I
suppose
I just crashed
oh my goodness
yeah well
let's try to the previous version
that's
okay
so I mean
you know doing something where we're
essentially saying and it's kind of like
Geo marker G or whatever else
uh you know
Geo
because what you want is all of that
stuff as an overlay I mean these
different elements as overlays
yes I mean we could have a single
property of solar eclipse that returns
why do that I mean why not why not just
say solar eclipse
uh
what is it really it's markers it's
solar eclipse
um
it's not graphics because that would be
the whole graphic
elements
um
doesn't sound quite right um no it's not
quite right but I mean so so the idea
would be
hey can we specifying which solar
eclipse and then you'll be specifying
like I just want the the region of
totality or something
and then that would become something
like this that you could style however
you want
that makes sense
yes but solar eclipse can now return the
polygons for example or the lines yeah
there's a long long list of properties
up above that uh lists all the things we
can do and some of those are elements
that are can be directly fed into
Geographics and that's how this graphic
was actually constructed
and what I'm what I'm saying is each of
those elements in the function solar
eclipse elements or whatever they are
solar eclipse markers whatever whatever
we call it
each of those elements you can call for
here
and then it basically gives you a bunch
of Primitives that you then feed into
Geographics
am I making sense
yes I guess what I don't understand is
the difference between solar eclipse
elements and solar eclipse because the
elements are properties of solar eclipse
so we could just put them in the second
argument of solar eclipse
well because I think the defaults will
be different
I mean but but
I mean okay so the difference
yeah so I think the difficult thing is
how to enter
um how to refill the the the the Styles
into the elements
yes
so I mean do you want a consumer
function or a programming function I
think if you get elements it's becoming
kind of a programming function where you
assemble it
well so caching well enough that if you
if I ask for several different things
from solar eclipse that's not going to
recompute anything
um it's it's getting better on that
front
yes
okay
um
so then
well let's say I just wanted to show the
path of the region of totality how do I
get that from here
so yes so there there is a property
right the um it's called
um
total phase polygon
oh yeah we had that before we had that
yes yes it is exactly it's one of the
one of the things that that actually
existed before
why is this taking so damn long
okay so now if I say Geographics
of red comma
that
is
the class again
that's that's completely new today
well then maybe I should use yesterday's
build
although I won't have other stuff all
right
um
right yeah
that looks different which has been odd
but anyway
okay lovely I don't know why it has
opacity mine has lower opacity like that
that's the default in Geographics for
all polygons
okay so if I said opacity
one
in in India stallion rapid Indio styling
why
um
because that's the that's the convention
in Geographic so the geopolygons need
data styling wrapped in
India styling
that's what you're starting off right
for example
why did it download the polygons again
no it's you're starting off right so
just telling of red is the styling comma
you know we really shouldn't okay fine
we really shouldn't have to download the
default World tiles we should surely
have downloaded those already
the we currently download all the tiles
I think it's a
yeah it's really it optimizes I assume
in this version We are continuing to
optimize vector vector Geographics
we continue yes but it's it's it it
doesn't go as far as I want it because
the time was needed in the astral part
but it the the new
underlying functionality for
astrographics and Geographics is getting
much better so it will get to Astro
Graphics this time but but not to
Geographics
okay Geographics I mean the surface of
the Earth is more important than the sky
yes but it's it's more difficult to
handle two it's not okay hustographics
is much simpler you can push back the
eclipse
okay
all right so
the question here is
there are all these elements
where where are the things that are sort
of visual elements
Umbra envelope polygon all that kind of
stuff yes and all the positions for
example all the contact positions for
the points and um yeah okay but the
labeling of those and so on
is in this there's some default labeling
here is that correct
yes that Jeff has added that
so a function that does much of these
for you would be
interesting
no but I mean it's added in this Eclipse
map case
and
I mean why couldn't we give like an
association with all kinds of crazy
things you can set
yes but we can certainly have a property
Graphics data that returns everything
then I I think you're suggesting Stephen
that this is almost like a its own new
object that you can feed into
Geographics and Geographics would just
ingest it is that right no no I'm saying
that when you say Eclipse map here there
can be additional options to that which
is an association of all the different
settings of different styling features
of this right yep yeah we can do that
I mean that seems like the right way to
handle I mean I I'm not convinced that a
separate function that makes this is
worth having
this is pretty simple
and it can get messy really quick
because you have which elements do you
want to turn on and then if you turn
them on what style do you want them to
have
well that's why I'm saying what are what
are those elements called they have
names up here right every element has a
name correct yes so the contact points
okay so then what we want to do
is we want to give essentially an
association where it says you know I
don't know exactly how this should work
I mean something like this isn't quite
right Eclipse map and then an
association that says
contact contact
point one
goes to and then the styling well
actually what we really want
I mean that could be a style or you
could have even more pedantically
contact point one function
that gives
you know
the geoposition of the contact point
and then you can wrap it in whatever you
want a marker or whatever you want
mm-hmm
because that's what you're ultimately
going to need to do if you want to make
a custom map
but the alternative is if you really
want to make that level of custom map
just extract the contact point and build
the map yourself
yep
yeah I gotta say I I just think people
are just going to use our default map
and the only thing they might say is you
know if there's a plot theme for example
that might be useful
or an ideal range we could just have
Eclipse map Regional range goes to this
area and we just show a nice map of that
area sure that would be good
I mean why not just have that be a top
level option to solar eclipse that only
applies to
you know I mean I think the Geo range
thing would be super useful if it could
tell me what eclipses are going to be
visible for this from this area
I mean that's a slightly different
meaning to Geo range I mean in other
words if I say an eclipse and I ask for
this Eclipse but in a place where it
isn't visible we don't want it well I
mean I guess we asked for this Eclipse
yeah I mean if we say Geo range we don't
specify a date then giving us the next
eclipse visible from that Geo range
seems like the right thing to do I see
it's a bit like the option Eclipse type
which looks for the eclipse the next
eclipse of that type
is exactly the thing that I've wanted to
do a zillion times it's like when is the
next going to be an eclipse from
wherever
now another thing I presumably I can get
the Geo region and I can say is this
town in this region right so if I if I
get that for the next solar eclipse how
do I get okay total phase polygon so I
can say something like how do I find out
if a particular town is in this region
go with NQ is that right yep
get that polygon again
uh during NQ of the polygon comma
let's say
New York City
okay so now how do I find
the
the cities that are within this so is
that Geo
what's that called Geo
what is that called
yes entities
of City comma polygon I think I tried
this the other day and ran into some
timeout problems I asked the uh Geo team
about that and I think they're looking
they're working on it
I think it's a timeout I think because
it works for administrative divisions it
just doesn't perhaps you feel the way I
it may be the other order regenerative
yeah sorry still there this is the
reversaler
well let's say
oh God yeah this is what Jeff was
mentioning
that's not very impressive
ly hard
yes yeah those worked for me the other
day but well they don't work today yeah
at least on this prototype built and so
on
okay so my my statement is if you want
to build your own
picture you got to get The Primitives
out and
you know
the one thing we clearly need is the Geo
range
you know it will be good to try to cash
you know like like looking for eclipses
in the next hundred years in different
places and the last hundred years surely
we can cash that
than we should
okay
yep
uh
okay
so now what else should we look at
so another question we have is whether
to return dates so many of the
properties here are dates of course if
you are interested in the eclipse you
are going to be seeing do want all those
dates in your time zone but if you are
studying eclipses globally
the history of eclipses all over the
world do you want the results in in
the GMT song
why aren't we just giving a time zone
option it has and the question is is the
default
well I think it should be the same as
for now which is your local time zone
okay
I would think so I mean isn't that what
all date object date functions default
to your local time zone most do most yes
what doesn't I mean local time if you
specify a different place obviously
yeah okay
I guess because we are changing from to
to have so many many uh eclipses in this
function it's like 72
000.
comparing them fields
nicer in YouTube one but I understand
people will use them individually the
comparison is just going to work because
we know we're keeping the time zone so
if you say what's the time between these
things that to the second it's going to
give the right answer
yes yes of course of course yes
but I mean this is in your personal time
zone that you the one that you're in so
if the eclipse is off on the other side
of the Earth
it's still going to give when that
eclipse occurs in your local time zone
not in the local time zone of the
eclipse
right for example when you compare two
other references or books they're always
reported in in Universal time
yeah I understand I understand
understand well
hmm
I I understand it will be an exception
with respect to the other functions so
users can always specify Time song goes
to DMT
yeah I think they should I think they
should the thing people you know if
they're confused
and
they say that eclipse is happening in
the middle of the night for me how can
that be or is that a close appears to be
happening in the middle of the night
they're going to figure out a different
time zone
okay what's next to look at here okay
yeah so
yep
exactly yep and Eclipse type to look for
yup for a given particular eclipse
so NGO range should just be another
option here
okay
that can look for eclipses that are
visible within that Geo rage
now we've got to be a little bit careful
if you say view range Arrow or City
I don't know whether we have
um
you know what I'm saying whether whether
we don't have polygons for all cities
no it will be just mostly a point
right but so
that's still okay because the question
of is this eclipse visible from that
point
which is fine that's perfectly well
defined and presumably what Stephen
every time you say when an eclipse is
visible you always mean totality but if
it's a partial eclipse you don't want to
ever include those no no no no no I
think I think an eclipse being visible I
think it's any eclipse and if you say
Eclipse type Arrow total
right right yeah so so I mean a partial
eclipse
no a lunar eclipse I mean it's clearly
visible over half the Earth right right
something like that
so
but that's okay I mean you'll just see a
bunch of lunar eclipses and then you'll
say okay well fine I only want total
solar eclipses set the eclipse type
okay
all right what's next here it might be
an expensive operation to to look
through so many clipses so many polygons
absolutely yeah yes it is a progress
indicator
but I mean that's yes it's non-trivial
but I mean how else are you going to do
it
and again I think it's important to
Cache what we can
right that like we should be able to
have a bunch of polygons for a bunch of
you know eclipses in the last I don't
know 100 years or whatever it is and
then and next hundred years and then
you know we can easily do the test
against those
they're making sense yep
what's the average time I worked that
out for that thing I wrote about eclipse
is the average time between
eclipses were a given point on the earth
like a few thousand years I think
I think so it's quite a lot in in
general
right but that means within a few
thousand years every place on Earth will
have an eclipse so if you say solar
eclipse of you know my little tiny
village and wherever
if we had cashed
you know
how many thousands of years there's a
good chance that you will hit something
not enough in a in a in a century
perhaps we can create some sort of
reverse index of
some greed of the year of the earth I
see yeah that's my idea
yeah we just grid the Earth and we just
give a list for every grid Square on the
earth we just give a list of what
eclipses are candidates right and just
give results with some resolution yeah
well but I mean internally that's what
we would do so we would pick take the
Geo feature ask what grid squares it
covers you know or then just get the
list of eclipses because for every grid
Square
the um you know okay so claim okay if
if the grid squares are
let's say 100 miles on the side
okay that's a modest number of grid
squares
you know what is it 240 but going around
the earth squared uh
and
then each one of those
will have
I don't know I would guess you know from
our full date instead of 72 000 eclipses
I would guess each one of those well we
can just work it out it's it's one over
24.
uh 240 Square isn't it I mean it's it's
just you just break that number of
eclipses into roughly those good scores
because they're quite because the each
of Cups it goes over a bunch of
different grid squares but this is a
good approach we should just create that
cash
and then from a given point
we can easily pull up
yep because when we've got a small set
of comparisons to do and particularly if
we're looking for the next eclipse it's
a very straightforward piece of
comparison we just keep going until we
find one that covers that particular
point
I like it
yeah I think that's something I don't
know
so another property I would like to have
a look at is is about what we call the
the Panorama and and it's further down
in the scope section
why is it in the scope section if it's
not documented then it's not real
well it is documented the example I want
you to have a look is is the one called
the eclipse Cycles so the property is
documented it's it's a particular
example the output of yeah okay this one
so so there are these two numbers that
identify the eclipses I remember yes and
the sellers and the inex and so I was
thinking of having this property the
sunox Saros inexpanorama such that we
show kind of the the local area around a
particular Eclipse so that you have an
idea of where in this in the southern
series which are the vertical lines it
is because if it is closer to the
borders you know it's near so like like
a chromaticity plot there's a lot of
background detail here yep and then
you've got a point on that background
detail by the way I I hope somebody paid
attention to the thing I reported about
plotting colors on the chromaticity plot
and the the um
the horrible features of of them
are
um
you know being being able to uh
not being able to see those colors on
the chromaticity plot because they're
plotted in the same color as the
chromaticity plot
and I couldn't figure out how to plot
them in a different color
that would be a thing for shoddy
somebody could bring that to her please
I did so now but I don't know what I got
an answer
yeah I'll check on that
okay
all right so
yeah so so yeah I wanted to check on on
this idea of highlighting the the
position of a particular eclipse on the
background and we could color for
example I think we should color the
total eclipses of the debacle should be
so to have like layers of different
types why are this why is there that
good is that are those eclipses or what
was what is that good so those are like
five thousand points of our 72 000 those
are around 5000 eclipses each one is a
is a point
and it's a grid
in families in vertical families
and and the distance
um vertically it's always 18 years the
distance horizontal is about 38 years
looks like the kind of thing that should
be in my description of how eclipses
work
yeah this is a very interesting thing so
eclipses are uniquely there
uh so each unit is a single point
and then
um
so those are the eclipses exactly and
plaster into something weirdly different
and yep
and so it
when I when an eclipse is reported you
always say it belongs to Saras family
for example this is the one in two weeks
this is 134.
uh it's it's it's more or less arbitrary
okay
I mean they knew about Soros families
and Antiquity
yes and and those corresponds to I don't
know -200
okay okay so do you see that the total
plot we have in um Below in blue
so we have families from minus 400 or so
to 700.
foreign
and that corresponds to what range of
years
minus 13
000 to plus 17 000.
okay
well okay so when that started
nobody was recording eclipses
right so this is because we we can
compute obviously yes obviously they
might have been studying eclipses but
they were probably throwing rocks at it
or something
um
okay
Okay so
the issue is so for example
Computing so we've got this whole how
are you specifying which region to plot
in this default Source index panorama
so so right now what we are doing is
that for a gift for the eclipse at the
at the center we go around a thousand
years back and I thought or a thousand
years forward yeah but I mean that's
totally arbitrary it could be 100 years
as well exactly but we need some margins
so that we have the full family a family
a service family will last for many
hundred years potentially A Thousand
Years
and so in order to make sure that the
vertical line is complete
well I mean we could just decide that
it's
I mean but this cut off this
is a space like hypersurface but it's
some kind of time
some kind of weird
you know I don't even know what it is
exactly but it's some what is it
actually
I mean that's obviously the time
I don't understand it well enough what
this sort of Cycles actually are
to understand why I mean that's that's
kind of like where
well okay so so these are families of
eclipses that are for example vertically
always separated by 18 years it's very
precise 18 years and a few days
and this yes these are front and the
inclination it's just this quotient of
18 and 38.
and so
it's so or horizontally the two eclipses
are separated by an index which is about
38 years and vertically it's a Saros
which is about 18. okay and so
then eclipses jump around so the next
one will not be next to it they are
jumping on all around this this plot
yeah more or less it will be nice to
have a picture I would like to see a
picture that shows the the uh the
trajectory in in the Soros index space
yeah yeah that's a good idea we can do
that okay
uh
but the issue is
you want
a
I mean clearly
this thing here
I mean we could clearly have a property
Soros in x
series or Cyrus MX coordinate or
something Saros index value which gives
a pair so that gives you the position of
that Center Dot right
I have to say that my tendency would be
to not make an arbitrary plot here
but just to have an easy way for people
to get a big bucket of Soros and x
coordinates
I see
because I see there's so many different
kinds of styling you might want here and
you might want you know it's just it's
very unclear and if what you did was to
say you had a thing which said
you know either within the Soros range
or we have annotation
in the first argument we have annotation
for all the eclipses between two dates
so I understand your point so we could
do solar data so solar sorry solar
eclipse of date one date two all that's
the notation for give me all the
eclipses between
one and two and then in the second
argument we have this property you are
suggesting called Saro cynics for
example yeah another return yeah
I mean it should be very straightforward
honestly it's easier than this
duh that's essentially what this is
doing this is a graphics is the better
way to do it yep
okay and then if you want to highlight
the current Eclipse you just you know do
that with this
uh so the only question is the Soros NX
result for single eclipse
is going to be a single turn
pair whereas
the other case is um
uh what am I saying is is a um
uh as a list of pairs what is that
consistent
Yes actually it will be an event Series
so our rule is that when you have a list
of eclipses in the first argument and a
property in the second we return an
event series
that that's that's what was done before
so we'll keep it up okay so sorry
an event series but when when you're
giving sorrows in X indices
then you're still giving an event series
which has the actual dates of those
things exactly and then the value is the
saracenix index so this particular
function would say values of solar
eclipse blah blah blah mm-hmm
that seems pretty nice and that that way
my plot that I was asking for
is Trivial to make because you're just
threading you've got the things in order
in their event series order
and so you literally just take that
sequence and that gives you the the you
know the path
yeah I like that users might also want
to keep the keys to do tool tips to see
the various dates of the points yeah or
other things all right Jose are there
any other pairs other than Saros and NX
are there other indices that people
might want to pair up or are these the
only two that are relevant
these are the fundamental ones okay
there are other Cycles
um but these are the ones we are
exposing because these are the
fundamental ones okay
great all right anything else what else
no I I think this is
uh the main questions right yeah any any
other one from you uh Jeff
not off hand
sorry go ahead and this thing I'm
planning to you know put out yep the you
know this Eclipse piece
um
I was thinking of having some kind of
appendix which shows you know how to
compute things in our technology stack
in a bit more detail
and uh
uh so you know I'll be playing with
these things I was thinking you're
probably going to want to expand you
mentioned the selling elements in your
blog but you don't really go into detail
and we now have stuff you could do that
with
okay yeah
suggestion yeah that's the next thing I
don't think I talked about unless it was
implicit
um and it seems like a nice way to think
about eclipses I don't really understand
the meaning of an index though other
than it's an index with a d missing
within the Soros cycle
it's a property that was recently
discovered I think in the 1950s which is
very impressive given that the sados was
known by the Greeks yes but what is what
doesn't index what is the interpretation
of an NX so these are numbers that come
from periodicities in the orbits of the
Moon and the Earth so they they reflect
something some some physical periodicity
so the key fact is waiting in long
enough so that the geometrical
configuration of sun earth and moon is
very similar so that you get nearly the
same Eclipse again
right and in fact when you compare the
different eclipses of the same Saros
family they look very similar only a
little bit transposed well so you're
saying that the time you have to wait
to see this as of order 38 times 18.
is that right that's the order of a
family yeah of a full service family
it's hundreds of years many hundreds of
years yes yes yes no I understand that
but I'm just saying
look excuse me this the second
coordinate mm-hmm
uh
the fact that there is periodicity with
respect to
you know
in the end it's dotting into different
index values it's not sequentially going
through in X values no no just like
you know in the and and so your claim is
that it wasn't obvious
that there was additional regularity
Beyond
the fact that
I mean
everything is on a saurus cycle
but most 18-year period things on the
sorrow cycle aren't eclipses right
between two elements of the same set of
cycle there are many other eclipses
yes
so you have to wait 18 years to get the
next element in a sales family no I
understand
so there are many many families playing
at the same time I understand
but I don't quite understand why the
indexes
explain again why the indexes were not
discovered until 1950 or 1950s
because the their their similarities
between eclipses horizontal is is much
smaller so people didn't realize that
these two eclipses B were together in
some sense vertically they look very
similar the geometric configuration
vertical is is very similar because this
period
of
um of 18 years corresponds to procession
of the orbit of the moon
yeah it's a fundamental geometric effect
okay so where's the 38 coming from
some other
some other combination of numbers in the
in the motion of of the Moon around the
Earth
but it doesn't have a clear physical
interpretation
weird I mean but it's very clear in this
picture it's very clear yeah
that's absolutely weird
there's got to be some way of
understanding that even if it's some
you know number theoretic combination of
uh
periods or something I mean especially
with a number as small as 38 years
yeah
for example I noticed that we have many
cycles in our quantity system but inex
is not there yet so just an example of
how weird this number is
and present
so I'm going to ask for it to be added
to to to find the value of a particular
uh
let's see here
you just look up
Stars oh this is Soros index Panorama
let's see what does it listed here
um
blah blah blah
yep so that's that's uh
well Solutions
sorry I think I I read here I've been
saying
38 but it's 29. oh I said it wrong
but so this dude
might or might not whatever this is I
don't know
but
huh
okay the Sorrows would reduce the
distance is diameters and rates emotion
of sun and moon with considerable
accuracy
total eclipse is nearly always followed
by a total one annular one by an annual
one okay
moreover tracks on the Earth's surface
are very similar
okay
okay let's track something at the
surface
um
the sake of which I suggest the name
Megalosaurus
I guess dinosaurs were known at that
time so
maybe there wasn't yet a Megalosaurus
uh
but where is the thing here
well who knows as usual the history is a
bit complicated
I mean that this appears to be a certain
John and Stockwell not this this guy
now as you know about this one I I had
to write about the Belgian
author in the 50s who was the one
suggesting that the eclipses must be
presented in this diagram yeah
okay well
interesting all right sounds good
anything else we need to cover here
no not today I think we have all the
information we need to complete this one
straight excellent all right see you all
soon bye for now bye